what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video get
ready my friends because House of the
Dragon is on its way about an hour ago
HBO officially announced they will be
showing new footage from House of the
Dragon second season in one day during
their convention in Brazil all of their
social media accounts have been updated
with new images of Alison and rira and
they said the first look at House of the
Dragon second season will be brought
with Fire and Blood I don't know about
all of you but I'm very excited we have
been waiting waiting for well over a
year to finally see what will happen in
this new season now they haven't said if
they will release the new footage online
for all of us to see right now they're
only saying it will be shown during
Brazil's ComicCon I'm hoping they will
officially release it for us as well
even if they don't release it themselves
I'm sure a fan will film it on their
phone and upload it online anyway so
make sure your notifications are on
because we could see House of the
dragon's first official teaser or
trailer shortly after it's shown at the
convention now we did hear some
information about about this new trailer
a few weeks ago for those of you who
don't know HBO held an event in New York
City where members of the media were
able to watch it first after they saw it
some of them were saying House of the
Dragon second season will be an epic
reemergence into the world of Westeros
as I've said in another videos House of
the dragon's new season will have
moments and events that shock millions
of fans the second season of House of
the Dragon will not only be better than
its first but it will also be more
exciting than season 7 and eight of Game
of Thrones we won't have to worry about
HBO switching out the actors anymore or
skipping ahead several years after each
episode now House of the Dragon will
unfold like a standard show only far
more interesting and heart-wrenching the
dance of the Dragons is now here so we
will see how stargaryen immediately go
to war against their own family for the
iron throne in Game of Thrones we only
saw Daenerys have the Three Dragons but
in House of the Dragon damn near every
Targaryen will have their own we will
see over a dozen dragons in the sky
small and large rain down fire all over
Westeros it will without a doubt be the
hottest summer in recent memory we
already have a good idea of how this
season will unfold now if you're not
interested in hearing about any of the
set leaks I would recommend stopping the
video now I will be giving a brief
description of what should happen in
some of the next season's episodes
according to a number of different
sources the name of the first episode
will be a son for a son this is in
reference to Damon and reneir wanting
revenge for the death of luc's valeron
now that reneir lost son she will want
Allison to suffer the same fate this is
when Damon will have someone hire
assassins to slip into the red keep and
avenge Luc haries if you're familiar
with George R Martin's fire in blood
then you will know this is what leads to
one of the most shocking moments in
House of the Dragon history remembers
them only as blood and
cheese one night Queen Helena entered
the Royal apartments with her daughter
and two sons to put them to bed without
warning blood and cheese burst in
daggers in hand they told her that AET
was owed a son for a son blood and
cheese demanded shichu which son would
be ripped from her forever Queen Helena
pleaded with the men to kill her instead
but they refused weeping Helena named
her younger son
Meo perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand or perhaps because
the older boy was King agon's firstborn
son and heir
you hear that little boy cheese
whispered to the younger son your mama
wants you dead as you can imagine the
battle of the dance of the Dragons will
enter a whole new stage after this in
that first episode we should also see
rira's other son Jace as he's on his way
North looking for allies for his mother
he will make stops in the veil white
Harbor and Winterfell while on that
Journey there's even been some evidence
of what Jace will do after he's become
friends with Lord Stark of Winterfell it
seems there also going to go to the wall
where they will visit with the knight's
watch now these scenes with the knight's
watch had me very interested because
there's also evidence that we will see
the army of the Dead next season as they
were filming new scenes for the season
someone snapped a photo of these images
on set if you zoom in on the photo you
will see there are different members of
the army of the dead as of right now we
don't know what that actually means Jay
and Lord C and Stark very well could see
the army of the Dead while they're at
the wall another option is maybe Jace or
Lord Stark imagines what they look like
as the knights watch is describing
what's out Beyond the Wall we might see
the night King White Walkers or the army
of the Dead in a flashback scene as well
I don't know how HBO will introduce them
in the new season but it seems they will
be there One Way Or Another We're also
going to see a major battle in the
middle of the season during episode four
the name of that fourth episode is a
dance of dragons it will be the battle
at rook's rest where we will see one of
the most incredible dragon battles from
A Song of Ice and Fire history there
have been hundreds of set leaks while
they were filming the battle a number of
the main characters will be there like
King aegon and his brother Amon one ey
as well as Sir Christen Cole and Rainey
Targaryen I'm thinking this battle will
most likely rival the Field of Fire
battle in Game of Thrones when Daenerys
ambushed A Lannister army with drogon
and her to thraki soldiers what has me
most excited about the battle at Rooks
rest is the dragon attack we will see
overhead there will be a three-headed
dragon fight while aegon and Amon fight
rainy as Ries and mes blanketed sir
Christian troops and dragon flame two
other dragons Rose into the sky aund on
vagar and King Aon himself on the
gleaming Sunfire to her credit rainy
didn't flee Dragon fought dragons and a
second son blossomed in the sky in The
Following episode which will be the
fifth episode we should see the Fallout
from that battle there is some footage
of what happens in the streets of King's
Landing
behold the trats are Dragon
[Music]
Mele as you can see they have the head
of rainy's dragon melees they're showing
everyone what will happen if you go
against them now according to other
source the final episode of House of the
Dragon second season should set up the
next major battle in House of the Dragon
season finale the C snake will leave
driftmark and sail on his ship in full
battle armor many fans already believe
this will be the beginning of the battle
of the gallet it's famously known as one
of the bloodiest sea battles in all of
Westeros history thousands of men will
die inh house valeron's incredible Fleet
will lose nearly onethird of its size
what's going to make the battle even
more heartbreaking is when we're near
loses another air and dragon
unfortunately we will not see the battle
next season since it was shortened by a
few episodes we're going to have to wait
until season 3 before we get to see what
happens during that battle thankfully
George R Martin has already confirmed
they're about to start working on that
season here soon although it is very
likely most of this will happen next
season nothing is officially confirmed
until we finally see it air on HBO I'm
not going to go over every episode
because I do want to leave some things
open for your imagination I'm assuming a
lot of you already know what will happen
because you've read Fire and Blood again
make sure your notifications are on
because you never know when HBO will
release the new trailer online like with
every other season I will be here with a
full breakdown video as soon as they do
as always I have to thank all of you for
watching this video I hope each and
every one of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon because there's
a lot more videos heading your way I'll
see you then
bye
for
[Music]